in this video we are going to try to
beat minecraft with only
one part i can't do it regularly here's
the deal we have an hour and a half the
timer just started ticking
joey jaws doodle three random
subscribers that we pulled from our
discord server you each get ten thousand
dollars if we beat the ender dragon
let's go can i go and start go the timer
is counting down
everyone begin go run run i'll get wood
everybody get at least like five logs go
go
go go go go go at least it's not ten
thousand you split it's ten thousand
dollars for each of you
oh my god i'm gonna buy so many order
mcflurries dude hey
he really does watch the videos enough
about the oil mcflurrys we need to
strategize if you guys want thirty
thousand dollars
we need to have plans true number one
priority is shields
says i've ever beaten this game solo is
um two hours
and 30 minutes so oh what what but this
isn't solo this is six of them yeah
there's six of us just the fact that
you've beat the game is good
listen we could do this what do you guys
mean you act like this is easy
carl there's a iron golem over here if
you want to try to kill it yeah that
sounds like a you job that sounds like a
you idea
if the golem hits me once i'm dead bring
it on big boy let's go
oh god oh no where's dream when you need
him honestly all right here we go we're
youtubers here
too you know yeah we're all really good
oh i accidentally died i forgot to have
one heart
who died what i took fall damage from
that let's try to trap the gold why do
we need to do it we need to kill him so
we can get iron all right there we go we
got him we got him
let's go yo i found iron guys girl did
you happen to grab my uh
my pickaxe there no i couldn't find it
all right cool
carl is highly sus we might need to
eject him we need to get to the nether
like soon
what how do i keep dying hey hey
gentlemen just you know five minutes has
already passed by
five minutes did you guys find my stuff
no
chill chill chill chill where's my stuff
oh baby zombie
oh
why is he coming after me get him
oh oh no he killed me oh he killed all
three of us triple kill
that's what you guys get for not sharing
watch this okay
gentlemen we need to get our crap
together what is our priority right now
what do we need
not dying more iron less dying oh
look who has all the power now creeper
oh man if we do one new thing each time
we die
then it was a win one hour 22 minutes
and 10 seconds left
we can do this this is absolutely doable
this is 100 possible these skeletons
have aimbot
don't forget all three of you could have
ten thousand dollars in an hour and all
you have to do is kill a stupid dragon
i'm gonna get a prius guys i'm getting
wool for beds don't worry
i have a water bucket and a flint and
steel all right perfect now we just need
a we need a lava pool guys i'm gonna
venture off on my own and find tons of
sheep i'll be the sheepslayer that just
sounds like murder
dude i am stressing creeper oh man oh no
oh no i've never needed to play
minecraft so hard in my entire life
10 minutes has gone by 10 minutes you
got a shield dude i have five in fact
five shields oh shields are gonna be a
game changer now it's time to start
playing baby yeah i'm gonna pull a dream
i'm just running thousands of blocks and
i don't see any sheep dude i swear i'm
on my oh i found sheep let's go
everyone in case you forgot you only
have one heart you have to like relearn
the game because
one fall that would take one heart is
gonna kill you
well you know what it might be hard but
you know winning thirty thousand dollars
isn't supposed to be easy oh my gosh i'm
on edge this whole game
this is so tense man i tell you oh wait
hey there's a nether portal over here
oh yeah chords chord scoring f3 f3 uh uh
uh i don't know guys it's 24 24. the oh
shoot oh oh oh oh
i'm pillaring up oh gosh chandler how
are you holding up doing great
who just released a demon out of their
throat i am stuck on top of this tower
until someone comes and save me
carl i'm concerned for you how much more
time until it's day time
is chandler even still here i'm i'm in
the caves in the cut man what are y'all
doing yeah if anyone's wondering i'm
still on top of a tower surrounded by
zombies
hey i see you hey do you see me who's
that oh there you are
yeah save me okay everybody armor makes
it multiple hits to kill you
we need a new bed dude i got beds for
all of you i got beds for days just so
everyone's aware uh over
20 minutes has a lap 20 minutes i've
done at least
20 times to be clear dream's fastest
record he's beaten minecraft by now oh
my god
we need to get to another like asap like
a sap
hey what's up what up dog oh the chest
is more important than me all right
i see how it is i found a lava pool
all right all right all right chords
chord chords all right i'm going to
start building it now bro look at these
pro strats i'm doing right now
people are so impressed attention
everybody we officially have
under an hour remaining oh my god
59 minutes and 18 seconds to be exact
hey
i want you to look at the uh achievement
achievement list for a second
because three two one
wait it's taking a little second oh it's
not transferring me i'm coming with the
bed
oh jimmy where are you behind you oh
get away no oh my god
uh no carl we both just died and lost
everything right
at least we're not the ones competing
for money
everyone watching do not play minecraft
with one heart is the most rage inducing
impossible thing ever i really do mean
that this might be the most rage
inducing video we've ever done
trying to build a house out of
netherrack not feeling good
i am stuck in a lava pool and i can't
get out
i'm safe i just need daytime and i have
multiple resources it's still night time
guys
oh wait wait guys guys guys big brain
play who here has a bet
i have two beds me everyone leave
besides him leave leave
leave leave leave all right sleep sleep
sleep sleep i'm in a bed
the time's still ticking down even
though we left i'm sleeping okay okay
wait wait
wait everyone back in here let's go all
right rejoin rejoin
hey 500 iq plays let's go baby when you
guys win 30 grand just buy me a taco
no i had all the gold and stuff guys oh
dude did you wait you headed on you
chandler yeah yeah dude oh uh ender
pearl
hey i found one oh yo i'm getting beds
for days we'll be able to set our
response wherever we want
carl i have a stack of gold nuggets
perfect oh oh
oh i see one i see one so carl how do i
kill this i'll make a boat make a boat
this is terrifying
all right all right did i do it i can't
lay it
oh my god half a heart i am around so
many
pigment right now i kind of want to hit
one yeah we're killing it guys we're
actually getting on track dude if we get
hit by one
blaze we're done oh i found piglets i
found a piglet
guys we have 38 minutes left in the
competition
somebody working on blazer rods we are
trying why is the nether like it is i
don't know we have the worst spawn of
all time i think that we got the only
nether that doesn't have a
freaking fortress dude oh there's a gas
no
i think i've had found a fortress
what there's one inside there's one
inside
i can't get to where i was at man on the
left oh my god
we don't even know what we're doing
anymore died so many times there's a
spider
a guest a gas sponge my stuff's still
down there
no way gentlemen we have under 30
minutes to beat minecraft
if you each won ten thousand dollars dig
deep dig deep we're digging deep let's
go
don't give up anyone wait dig deep
meaning dig straight down dig straight
down in the nether
oh bruh i actually found it where chords
do slash chords do slash chords right
now before you die
i i swear to god i think this is one is
just one of those piglon like guild
things or whatever those are
i [ __ ] so frustrating you fall like four
blocks and you die
i've never been so scared of falling it
is so hard
we're gonna win don't don't you give up
don't you dare give up hope
oh my god i'm so dead guys oh no
have we even found the blaze spawner yet
no we haven't found a fortress yet we
thought we did oh my goodness
here's a pro tip don't die
it's nighttime i got killed by piglet
five four three two
one there's now 20 minutes remaining in
this competition
god hey that's enough time that's enough
time for a dream run
we're not losing we're not losing you
guys are each winning 10 grand totally
yeah
jimmy i hear the sarcasm i don't
appreciate it
guys who are on the nether right now
it's do or die either you find some
blaze rods or you don't get 10 grand
it's up to you guys
i'm looking bro there's two gas shooting
at me oh my gosh
yay stewart died let's just die guys
there's 16 minutes left find the
freaking fortress
dude i don't want to go back i don't
jimmy you made this channel to have us
have fun
i'm going to make the best decision that
we could make for this video
the timer hit zero and all three of you
didn't win ten thousand dollars each but
i'm gonna give you a chance for
redemption one of you is gonna walk away
with ten grand
oh god three-way duel all of you have
one heart still last remaining gets to
10 grand
starting now good luck hey everybody
oh oh no oh there you go oh john's
dead no what oh
joey versus jody and doodle all right 10
grand on the life doodle how old are you
the twitch terms of service i'm over
that
leave me alone wait oh oh oh
oh joey oh my gosh joey
how does that feel to just rip money out
of your friend's hands
i've never felt so good about murdering
i'm gonna be honest we couldn't beat
minecraft so they didn't all get 10
grand but at least joey did what's your
final words before the video ends
smash like on mr beast's video and have
fun sounds good everyone subscribe and
we'll see in the next video
down with the king